Cuántas personas viajaban en el bote
pesquero los supervivientes han sugerido
que al menos 750 iban a bordo incluidos
unos cien niños el barco tardó menos de
15 minutos en hundirse por completo y
ahora Presenta una de las mayores
tragedias de inmigrantes en el
Mediterráneo
con decenas de muertos y desaparecidos
el mundo se pregunta por qué nadie
intervino antes fotografía por la
impactante foto tomada por helicópteros
de la guardia costera griega muestra a
personas con las manos abiertas pidiendo
ayuda los testimonios de las personas
que conocimos fueron Igualmente
impactantes nos dijeron que pedían ayuda
la embarcación partió de un puerto
egipcio Y recogió sus pasajeros en el
este de Libia a primera hora de la tarde
del martes fue detectado en el
Mediterráneo por la agencia de fronteras
de la ue frontex los guardacostas
griegos afirman que establecieron un
primer contacto a las 14 horas del
martes y que el capitán no solicitó
ayuda según el Ministerio griego de
transporte marítimo se pusieron en
contacto con el barco en repetidas
ocasiones pero en todas ellas la
respuesta fue que querían seguir
navegando hacia Italia el miércoles
hacia la 1:40 de la madrugada los
guardacostas Se recibieron el aviso de
que el motor de la embarcación se había
averiado Poco después de las dos de la
madrugada el barco se volcó Pero según
la ONU los guardacostas no tienen todo
el relato
los supervivientes nos dicen que la
embarcación se volcó mientras era
maniobrada al ser arrastrada por los
guardacostas helenos
este representa el último caso mortal de
contrabandistas que llenan los barcos de
personas desesperadas dispuestas a
arriesgar su vida para llegar a Europa
continental nueve egipcios han sido
detenidos entre ellos El capitán del
barco en este contexto varios líderes
europeos han pedido un cambio en la
política migratoria incluida la creación
de rutas legales de migración